comm.editsweb analyse mit rough 3.0 die
looks von phantom die sind schon draußen
von deinem album jedoch zwei wird das
die erste single das war die erste
single nennt man sowas wenn er sie nicht
singen ist sowas wenn es nicht
veröffentlicht wird also wenn es nicht
die single okay die wird super kauft
genommen eigentlich vorab videos um zu
sagen gut kommt extra was willst du was
will der künstler damit sagen phantom
phantom das quasi mein körper meine
kunst sich auf ein medium presst oder
offen medium verwandelt quasi in luft
auflöst sozusagen auf in irgendeiner
around cloud ein lied wird was für ihn
existiert okay
der fall hat man durch tag welttag
friends tag fans nach dem willkommen
alle die mich nicht kennen versteht sich
ich bin hier so was wieder dirigent
versteht sich schieß mit rosen aus
schrotflinten zu schönen violinen das
ist das ein schönes bild für mich also
ich schieß mit rosen aus schrotflinten
also ich schieße mit einer schrotflinte
rosenhaus für mich ein sehr schönes bild
so schön violinen dass die welt abstrakt
ein opus ist vollendet das möge beginn
versteht sich von selbst
nein mein werk heißt opus ja genau ist
vollendet es möge beginn dort wo früher
meine arme waren hängt jetzt ein ganzer
kabelstrang also sozusagen ich
transformieren mich zu diesem phantom zu
diesen bogen allen dingen was dann ja
wie immer existiert so zu sagen ich
meine musik maschine hängt jetzt ein
ganzer kabelstrang dann kommt was sehr
lustig ist hängt jetzt ein ganzer
kabelstrang ich spiele ganz entspannt
auf meinen lorbeeren tetris betrachtet
im zirkus des goldenen käfigs das
bedeuten sagte man ruht sich aus auf
seinen lorbeeren also ich relaxe ich
spiele tetris sozusagen also noch spiele
tetris auf meinen lorbeeren betrachtet
im zirkus des goldenen käfigs also ich
betrachte wie sich quasi die löwen
zerfleischen in diesem eigentlich gehts
denn allen sehr gut
einen ganzen chor und chormusik und co
stars trotzdem zerfleischen sie sich
betrachten zirkus des goldenen käfig
denn genau dort wo meine zähne bahn
wächst mir ein säbelzahn das hat keine
bedeutung in independent die spiele
tennis mit dabei das ich mache so zu
sagen was ich will mein leben war aufbau
wieder abriss denn ihr das haus braucht
seine basis versteht man also mein leben
war aufbau wieder abriss wieder weg mit
dem dreck denn jedes haus braucht seine
basis das erstmal eine gute basis
schaffen
hast du hast keine basis immer behalten
genau also ich habe sozusagen mein haus
gebaut was aber nicht wirklich gut
gestanden weil die basis nicht stark
genug war ein lieber weg um noch mal hat
noch an deinen ein alaba sind näher an
der basis weiterarbeiten stabiler wird
dann wieder aufbauen habs martys statt
blut drüsen stadt bei dann hab ich jetzt
flug düsen
das heißt so zu sagen ich bin eine wird
das phantom wasser entsteht mit
thematisch stadt bluten das bedeutet
halt auch nicht aber stadtbahnhof flug
diesen und ich blicke in den nun scheint
es kann nicht mal der tod scheine ich
und meine fans mir bleiben für immer
denn dieser sound wird irgendwann ein
phantom sein
dieser sound wird irgendwann ein phantom
sein um das leben für immer
das heißt du lebst in deiner musik für
ihn für immer
das war schon also zweite pakistan für
immer immer immer im ipod aller klassen
schüler klassen schüler ein wort was ich
gefunden habe weil es sich reimt aber
das gut trasse ist es gar nicht mehr auf
den anderen satz ich weiß gar nicht
warum ich das verhalten habe eigentlich
ging das so für immer die close für die
klosterschwestern um die waffenbrüder
genau und dann blabla klassen schüler
und dann habe ich das klosterschwestern
waffenbrüder vor ausgelassen und hab
dann klassen schüler einfach übrig
gelassen und das wort bedeutet nichts
niemann aufgerollten klasse heißt es
schulklassen klassen schüler sozusagen
der schüler ja klar aber schulklasse
gibt es aber nicht klassen schule
klassen schüler gibt es nicht es werde
wieder große riese ja so lange ist ein
argument dafür gibt sogar so gern ein
fremdwort werden ja ein heimnetzwerk und
erfinden werde bereits an
das müssen wir gleich ein dass der hose
hat eine sekunde gerettet aber jetzt
sieht man aber geredet werde unterhose
ist schimmel
das wort kann ich noch nicht doch
tautologie tautologie weißer schimmel
talsohle meint auto - oder ein
pleonasmus das ist richtig
das war ein klares muss aus meiner brust
punkten subwoofer pausenlos bass wieder
die zur musik maschine und da wo mein
herz war schlank tausende wort versteht
sich ich fliege nachts durch diverse
bars die musik in den vasen erzeuge
wellen in ihren jackie glas tee was
übrigens meine hände sind halt von sich
klemmen sie auf köpfe über töne den
streit zwischen engel und teufel
verstehst du die ohren zugedrückt wird
hört man den teufel
mich mein phantom ein drittes auge ist
ein rohdiamant das dritte auge das auge
der erleuchtung access ist ein
rohdiamant das heißt es ist noch nicht
ganz ausgefeilt ich sehe noch nicht
komplett durch sieht kids ins koma
fallen
bravo links wodka rechts dieses leben
ist eine go-kart-bahn egal mein motorrad
braucht keinen schlaf ihnen drogen junk
wenn der motor scheint wirklich zum
hologramm und fliege weiter wind von
thom durchs land aber da man ja ganz
bietet sein was bedeutet das alles was
dann ja etwas auf leben ist eine
go-kart-bahn trickkiste
doch wie geht es in zukunft aber das ist
gut das ist klar
bravo links wodka recht dieses leben des
innsbrucker keiner warum brach links
wehrte ließ die bravo als kind du siehst
die foto lovestory
das hat mit seinem wort graffiti ich
möchte sein wer den wodka wein kippen
dieses leben ist hart waren wie gesagt
an ein zwölfjähriges oder go-kart-bahn
der hat das nicht unter kontrolle der
fährt wohl will ich sagt egal wann
scheiß drauf motor an
ich fand trotzdem in dieser ghoga seines
lebens braucht kein schlaf ihnen drogen
junk also ich bleibe ich immer machen
wie er sich später einen ball an
und wenn der mond erscheint werde ich
zum hologramm wie ein werwolf sozusagen
wenn der mond bei der verwaltung werde
ich zu dem phantom und fliege weiter wie
ein phantom durchs land und verteile
mich weiter danach gucken im mondschein
es gar nicht meine tod scheint dieser
sound wie den phantom sein und dann am
ende kommt eine endliche lehmwände genau
eigentlich lebendig die börse habe ich
übrigens ein bisschen geklaut von smells
like teen spirit ich weiß nicht genau
was mich daran was mich da erst das
inspiriert hat weil im endeffekt man
hört jetzt keine parallele mehr aber
irgendwie hat mich das daran erinnert
endlich lebendig auch wenn ich weit weg
bin mein werk ist vollendet um das leben
für immer
also eigentlich lebendiges versteht nur
noch alle
böse und hässlich schönung zerbrechlich
mein werk ist vollendet ums lebe für
immer finden da muss ich sagen unser top
dem warten ja war ja fast als hätten wir
dieses gespräch
diesen song als hätte ich ihn gekannt
der tag vor dem interview weil so bis
zum wegen der zerrissenheit neuhausen
oder es spiegelt mich sehr dieses
verschweigen dass mitte spricht über ein
drittes auge
glaubst du dass das ist das da findest
du dass er hundertprozentig was ist wenn
du wenn dir ein guter song eingefallen
ist das ist das für ein gefühl
aber kommt das dritte auge oder naja das
ding ist ja das dritte auge dass in der
kita meditation im buddhismus und das
dritte auge etwas hast du quasi durch
meditation durch wenn der strom durch
die kundalini fließt und so weiter
da an mir ist dass ich bin ja kein
christ ich bin katholik ich praktiziere
das nicht also ein bisschen aber nicht
wirklich
das heißt wenn der song kommt mir aber
für mich sozusagen durch mein drittes
auges kommen durch den sechsten sinn
hast du manchmal das gefühl der ist ja
ganz selbst eingefallen sondern der ist
der eingang ist es eher eine eingebung
im wahrsten sinn des wortes 100 prozent
sagen ja viele musiker wirklich die
sagen das ist eben alles lügen
in dem moment wo mir das ein feld ist
das wie eine erneut klar ist es
hundertprozentig dass das gibt eine
schelle boom und was das problem ist
genauso wie mit den tönen gibt gab es
jedes thema schon einmal und wenn du
schon musik machst seit sieben jahren
acht jahren zehn jahren zwölf jahren
hast du die erleuchtung boombox von mike
tyson du freust dich aber drei sekunden
später merkst du dass du schon mal ein
song hat es worum es genau darum geben
die kurze depression längst ist scheiße
scheiße da kommt wieder in meinen mund
so weiter bis halt wieder etwas kommt
was es wirklich noch nicht gegeben hat
und dann kommt der zweite bohrung
somit also zweimal 2 dann wünsche ich
dir das noch oft zweimal beobachten
vielen dank dafür